well it was a weekend in the united
states so of course we had another one
of these unspeakable tragedies involving
guns and this one is particularly bad we
always have mass shootings in the u.s
it's hard to find a weekend without at
least one mass shooting but we had a
particularly bad one and this one
because of the rhetoric involved because
of the alleged manifesto left behind by
the
alleged killer
we actually have insight into the
stochastic terrorism element of this
situation so i'm going to explain it to
you
as a reminder tragically i've been
talking about stochastic terrorism on
this program for at least 11 years back
in 2011 i did a segment called
stochastic terrorism and violent
rhetoric
unpredictability of shooters and the
fundamental idea
is that given a large enough audience if
you pump out a particular message time
and time and time again focusing anger
and focusing resentment and antipathy
towards a particular group of
individuals
you will at a certain point
uh influence someone enough who says i'm
going to go and shoot bomb whatever the
case may be we've had instances of this
in the past and here we have one related
to so-called great replacement theory or
white replacement theory
and
critical race theory and all of it so
let's take it step by step
mass shooting took place over the
weekend at tops friendly market
supermarket in buffalo new york 10
people were killed three were injured of
the 13 victims 11 were black and two
were white and this was not a
coincidence this was not by mere chance
this is uh being considered a hate crime
the shooter live streamed part of the
attack on twitch twitch says they caught
it within two minutes and cut the stream
the shooter uh
is white
18 year old and deliberately traveled to
an area with a higher population of
black people because he wanted to kill
black people the shooter was wearing
body armor and a military-grade helmet
and armed with three firearms a
semi-automatic rifle a legisl allegedly
a bushmaster xm15
a hunting rifle and a shotgun that's
what we know right now and had a head
mounted camera that's the camera from
which the event was streamed
the suspect was captured alive and was
arraigned in the buffalo city court
on the day of the shooting represented
by a public defender felony hearings
scheduled to begin later this week in
front of a grand jury he's being held
without bail
now this is where it starts to get you
know oh don't make it political well
right-wing political media
literally wrote the script for this
guy's manifesto
he reportedly wrote the shooter an uh
180 page manifesto that was released
prior to the shooting i'm i'm not going
to publish the manifesto but you can
find it i'll give you some of the
highlights and there's actually a good
twitter thread by j.j mcnabb a fellow at
george washington university's program
on extremism
some of the things from the manifesto
the shooter self identifies as a white
supremacist fascist with neo-nazi
beliefs who is anti-high fertility
immigrants under the white replacement
theory
this is the idea that uh immigrants who
aren't white come to the u.s to have a
lot of kids to demographically take over
the country
he states he was radicalized online on
4chan and was inspired by brenton
terrance manifesto and live streamed
mass shooting in new zealand you might
remember that one the shooter chose his
target because it has a higher
percentage of black americans than other
nearby areas
the manifesto is 180 pages long dozens
of pages are nothing more than
anti-black and anti-semitic memes and
statistics and almost 100 pages
contained mind-numbingly boring info
about every piece of equipment he
considered taking on the shooting spree
now there is so much to talk about here
there's the mentally ill thing
right the this what oftentimes you know
we've seen this before and and i don't
do this but you often see the trend of
if the shooter is muslim then it's
radical beliefs that are responsible and
the community of the individual
if it's a young white dude
then it's a lone mentally ill guy whose
mental illness alone and not the fact
that the manifesto reads like a fox news
script are responsible
it's important to remember a couple of
things one
in some sense you can argue
any of these people are not mentally
right anybody willing to do this is not
mentally right
but when you look at the manifesto
it's perfectly cogent and coherent and
it's not someone who doesn't understand
the consequences of their actions and
most importantly most mentally ill
people are not violent most mentally ill
people never commit a violent act look
at the list of so-called mental
illnesses now i know that not all of
these are exactly the same category but
think about you know anxiety bipolar
disorder depression ocd paranoia
paranoid schizophrenia delusional
disorder borderline personality disorder
mania panic disorder ptsd
depersonalization derealization disorder
anorexia bulimia parasomnias kleptomania
this is a broad range of stuff
but the point is almost none of the
folks with those conditions ever become
violent now i get that something is
wrong with the people who are violent
but to say oh well this is just a
mentally
just a therapist solves this problem
ignoring the political motivations
ignoring the access to firearms ignoring
all of it
when you look at the manifesto it's
articulate fascist fascist
racist hate
linked to ideas that we see in corporate
media the talk about white birth rates
the document talks about critical race
theory that's something i mean listen
that
it's like a republican talking point at
this point in time it says that it's all
part of a jewish plot
and oftentimes there's anti-semitism in
this stuff it's the full complement of
the things they've been pushing openly
since trump became president even since
right before when his campaign started
now let's just look at some examples
here's ben shapiro democrats want open
borders they want to bring in tens of
millions of illegals to vote the biden
administration has done less than
nothing they're not talking about ending
title 42 which would basically allow the
borders to be swamped their own dhs is
estimating up to 18 000 people a day may
be descending on the border which of
course completely destroys whatever
semblance of order there is on the
border there isn't much there right now
so what do you make of the border
situation it's i think it's literally
criminal what biden and the
administration has done you know they
swore to faithfully defend and uphold
the laws of the united states and and
remember almost nothing different is
being done by biden versus trump at the
border it's not even like they're trying
it's not like they're trying and failing
right that would be bad enough mirror
incompetence would be costly enough but
they just want this open border this is
their policy program from the democrats
perspective they like it it's good uh
it's 225 000 people coming across every
month not every year every month the
amount of fentanyl that comes over every
month is enough to kill every american
twice over of course most of the people
uh brought over trafficked by cartels so
there's a human slavery component you
know the women and children are horribly
abused bonafide humanitarian crisis and
it's just bad it's bad for everybody in
arizona it's bad for the whole country
uh but this is the way democrats like it
and again i'm bold enough to to admit
the obvious right which is that they're
doing this so that someday they can
amnesty these people and make them
voters who they expect to vote democrat
this is an electoral strategy for the
democrats their policies are so bad and
so so we've already debunked this
extensively even if it was what
democrats wanted to do it's a terrible
terrible strategy
strategy and i've explained many times
why the math of it doesn't make any
sense but the point is here is that
anger at democrats deliberately dumping
in tens of millions of illegals into the
country that's not what democrats want
to do tucker carlson remember immigrants
make our country poorer and dirtier good
evening and welcome to tucker carlson
tonight here's a funny thing that we
noticed the other day people debate all
the time about mass immigration
what you never hear anybody do is make
the economic case for mass immigration
but as an economic matter this is insane
it's indefensible so nobody even tries
to defend it instead our leaders demand
that you shut up and accept this we have
a moral obligation to admit the world's
poor they tell us even if it makes our
own country poorer and dirtier and more
divided there i mean it's it's hard to
get more specific rhetoric than that
that is straight out of the manifesto
here's another tucker carlson clip where
he is doing the replacement theory
talking points that were echoed in the
shooter's manifesto
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown absolute contempt
for our customs our laws our system
itself and they're being treated better
than american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest the
democratic party is trying to replace
the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world but they
become hysterical because that's that's
what's happening actually let's just say
it that's true
if look if this was happening in your
house if you were in sixth grade for
example and without telling i remember
covering this at the time listen to this
your kid your parents adopted a bunch of
new siblings and gave them brand new
bikes and let them stay up later and
help them with their homework and gave
them twice the allowance that they gave
you
you would say to your siblings you know
i think we're being replaced by by kids
that our parents love more
and it becomes
this is the great replacement theory
stuff that was in the manifesto uh
charlie kirk has been pushing this stuff
president joe biden's department of
defense will accept 30 000 afghan
refugees in the military installations
following the collapse of kabul
boom
political
transformation there it is
let the country crumble do you know
there's five million displaced people in
afghanistan now
this was all intentional
joe biden let it fall apart to now say
oh i'm so sorry i guarantee you joe
biden's speech this afternoon we'll talk
about refugee assistance and relocation
support yep the entire point of getting
out of afghanistan was so it would go
poorly so that then they can bring in
people to replace white people from
afghanistan lauren bobert has done this
stuff yes there is um definitely a
replacement theory that's going on right
now we are killing american jobs and
bringing in illegal aliens from all over
the world world to replace them if
americans will not comply replace them
replace them so
there is serious responsibility here i'm
not saying there's going to be
accountability i'm not saying what
they're doing is criminal the term
stochastic terrorism is not a criminal
term it's a term that we as reasonable
people can say wow they repeat this
rhetoric and then the rhetoric is used
in a manifesto and it's what made this
guy go and seek out black people
i'm not saying you can charge any of
them i'm just saying we have to speak
honestly and acknowledge that these
ideas didn't come out of thin air now
one other note before we move on this
was not the only mass shooting this
weekend so yes there was the mass
shooting in buffalo but we also had a
mass shooting in milwaukee with 17
injuries on friday and we also had mass
shootings in houston texas laguna woods
california amarillo texas
as well as winston-salem north carolina
this weekend so always remember in the
united states of america there's never
just one mass shooting and we do
ultimately get to
the question of what do we do because
there's this fallacy of tolerance if we
tolerate the intolerant
then they go out
and kill people and they those people
that die no longer can practice that
tolerance there there is this uh uh
fallacy there and this problem that
needs to be dealt with and we're going
to keep covering all of this but we of
course we have to talk about what fox
news is blaming as well
without missing a beat in the aftermath
of the buffalo mass shooting where a
racist 18 year old using
quite literally fox news talking points
in a manifesto allegedly left behind
went and sought out black people
um killed 10 injured three 11 of the
victims black to white
fox news brought on a guest to speculate
about you know the violence has
correlated with the video games getting
really realistic and really violent
they're doing it
they're doing it with a straight face
look at this
i think of you know what must go through
the minds of these people like like the
guy yesterday who's accused of shooting
up that supermarket he's 18 years old
his whole life was in front of him and
now his life essentially
is over because of what he decided to do
do they not think about this before they
opened fire are they so wrapped up in
themselves as you say so psychopathic
that nothing else matters to them
you have to have a conscious to feel
that way and so no there's not it's a
blind obsession
it lacks empathy
thus it makes them so incredibly
dangerous
i i wonder you know it seems like these
things have gotten so much worse
since video
games became so realistic and so violent
uh
have you
done research or you know
learn that that video games uh
struggling even to have we know we want
to blame video games but i don't even
know how to put together a question tend
to just desensitize people to
the actual um results of pulling a
trigger i think in terms of causation
what the information shows us is that as
we become more disfranchised as
individuals and groups people leave a
faith for example the family units
become smaller or more
so this guy talks about leaving faith
and disfranchised
the guest doesn't even really know how
to respond even though john scott wants
to blame video games so uh every country
has violent video games the united
states is not unique in that do you guys
have any idea how much grand theft auto
i played growing up do you have any idea
how many people i have brutally murdered
in a video game since i was like 14
years old with every weapon imaginable
and i have never even thought about
committing a violent act i am not in any
way desensitized to real world violence
if anything the real world violence and
the shootings are what we've become
accustomed to because it is so frequent
but it is not the video games and other
countries with tons of video games don't
have this problem there's a ton of
gaming in europe there's a ton of gaming
in argentina in south korea there's an
insane video gaming world they don't
have a gun violence issue they also
don't have nearly as many guns which is
an interesting thing they also mostly
have access to mental health treatment
if you believe that that is actually the
the primary cause
and then we are a country without any
real access to that treatment you also
have to consider that so they've been
pushing this for 40 years or longer
first it was movies then video games we
have academic work on the topic
uh the best findings that i'm able to uh
uh find
uh include work from erica schar who has
been a guest on the show talking about
this from the university of
massachusetts
a study called violent video games do
contribute to aggression and and what
the study found is that while violent
video games
can generally
uh uh
promote aggression in some general sense
they don't make non-violent people
randomly go out and do shootings and
most importantly most importantly
as eric ashara has made clear
it is impossible to link video games to
mass shootings and this has been studied
and this has been debunked so i guess we
shouldn't be surprised
that fox news so quickly went to that
they seem to often do it but it is not
based in evidence let me know your
thoughts and remember that monday
memorial day will have our one day
membership special i hope that you're on
our newsletter at davidpakman.com if you
are monday memorial day you'll be
notified about this great opportunity to
get a highly discounted membership
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to join
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
so we spoke before the break about fox
news in the aftermath of the buffalo
mass shooting terrorist attack bringing
on a guest and john scott pushing on the
guests the idea that i don't know
since video games have become so
realistic and violent we've seen more
violent shootings and we've already
talked about the academic work on the
link between real world violence and
video games and uh there is no such link
now i want to show you something else
that fox news did in the immediate
aftermath of the buffalo shooting where
it's a
domestic
white guy
born here allegedly with three weapons
went and targeted black people
deliberately went and targeted black
people
fox news hosted a segment
where they made the case
that we really need to be worried about
the hispanic terrorists
coming
through the u.s mexico border they we we
just had this incident
and you're talking about something which
is not actually a statistical issue i'll
explain take a listen to this he is not
the secretary of homeland security he's
the secretary of homeland insecurity
because our country by the way this is
tom homan from the heritage foundation a
right-wing think tank safe
because like last month they admitted
they arrested 42 people on the screening
database terror screening database there
has been over 700 000 known got away
since joe biden became president how
many of them were on the terrorist
screening database are in the country
right now you're not going to tell me
out of 700 000 161 different countries
many of that
sponsored terrorism not a single person
came across that border not get arrested
that came this country do us harm this
is a national security issue of huge
proportions i've done this for 35 years
lawrence i've never been more concerned
about the safety of this nation than i
am under this administration the
secretary needs to be impeached on day
one when the republicans take back
congress and i told them that last week
when i met with them yeah what a
powerful declaration from tom homan now
let's let's remember
um we know a lot about immigrants to the
united states now is it impossible that
they always say you've got muslim
terrorists coming through the border
disguised as hispanics coming here and
doing terror well we know about the
terror attacks here and it's mostly
american-born white men that do the the
terror attacks in the united states so
let's just think it through
we know that if you take three groups
american-born individuals
legal immigrants to the united states
and illegal immigrants to the united
states the group that commits crime at
the highest rate is those born here in
the united states now it makes perfect
sense we shouldn't hear that and say
that that doesn't make any sense david
why would it be why would that it seems
that the immigrants should be the ones
committing more crime why
why
if you are here undocumented
you're aware
that any kind of police interaction in
some states where they have shown me
your papers laws
even just
a driving infraction
could end up with you getting deported
you know your status here is
undocumented so you are incentivized not
to be on the radar of law enforcement in
a way that a legal immigrant or a a
natural-born american would not be
natural-born americans know if i get
caught speeding doesn't matter what
state it's in i'm not getting deported
whereas an undocumented immigrant knows
that that is a possibility that's an
incentive for undocumented immigrants to
actually behave even better and they do
and they do
legal immigrants as well legal
immigrants also commit crime at a lower
rate
than domestic natural-born uh citizens
of the united states and it makes
perfect sense so there's like two or
three different layers here one is of
course that they're just wrong about
this idea that the ma the major
committers of crime here are
foreign-born they're not by rate right
okay so that accounts per capita for the
fact that there are more uh uh
natural domestically born individuals in
the country and number two
without a shred of irony an 18-year-old
us-born white guy targets black people
uh kills 10 and uh injures three 11 of
the 13 in total are black
and fox runs with video games or violent
and we've really got to do something
about terrorists coming over the
southern border no they're being born
here
they're being born here so there's sort
of a question as to whether people like
tucker
are going to cool it with some of the
great replacement stuff because it's so
directly linked to the shooting over the
weekend and this is this is the clip i
showed you is from the hard news
side of fox news so it's going to be
quite a scene um here's some interesting
new polling data since the draft from
the supreme court
leaked
which revealed to us that unless
something changes roe v wade will be
overturned in the next few weeks since
that leaked support for abortion rights
in most or all cases
has gone up to 60 percent which is the
highest level in two decades according
to a new nbc news poll let's look at
some comments about the polling from
mark murray who's the senior political
editor for nbc news results from the
poll abortion should be
always legal say 37 percent of americans
legal most of the time say 23 percent of
americans so in total 60 percent of
americans believe that abortion should
be always or mostly legal the combined
60
is the highest percentage on this
question going all the way back to 2003.
now you might say okay but hold on wait
a second david whoa whoa whoa
the draft opinion from the supreme court
makes it
uh just something states can decide so
the polling doesn't really change
because you could be against roe v wade
but still in favor of the state keeping
abortion legal okay well the draft
opinion would make it legal
for states to make abortion illegal and
that's ultimately the same thing at the
end of the day
on the question from the poll should roe
v wade be overturned and this goes to
that
only 30 percent believe that roe v wade
should be overturned that is up from 23
in 2018
but 63 percent nearly two-thirds of the
country
believe that roe v wade
should not be overturned that is down
slightly from 2018. now there's another
question here when we think about the
political impact of this forthcoming
decision we've been wondering what will
it do to the midterm elections will it
inspire
democrats and people on the left to get
out and vote for democrats by and large
for independent voters we know abortion
is not historically a big voting issue
for independents
but what might it do for voter turnout
for democrats we haven't had any new
polling that i've been able to find on
like a generic congressional ballot for
november since the supreme court
decision leaked it would be very
interesting to look at that data and
hopefully we will have it soon the the
other part of this by the way
when we see 60 of americans believe
abortion should be legal in most or all
cases that 60 is not represented in the
senate and as i've told you before the
senate is a fundamentally
anti-democratic body
you can have in the senate because every
state gets two senators you can have
50 percent of the population
uh i'm sorry you can have 50 percent of
the senate votes
represented by those who have only 17 of
the population in their states that's
extraordinarily lopsided and
undemocratic and it's considered a
feature
not a bug of the senate by many so we're
going to continue following the numbers
but support for abortions legality up to
record highs since the leaked supreme
court decision and we'll have more of
that polling data on our instagram you
can find us on instagram at david pakman
show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show alright everybody
buckle in these next two segments are
pretty pretty full on nuts over the
weekend donald trump spoke at another
one of these right-wing events of no
consequence this particular event was in
austin texas now we had a correspondent
on the ground talking to trumpists and
we're going to get to those videos in a
moment but first what did donald trump
say this is maybe
the most callous
moment
of donald trump's political career now i
know he made fun of the disabled
reporter
and yelled out where's my
african-american he's had all these
cringe moments but this is wacky trump
going on stage and saying
i think they had a tragic event in
buffalo referring to the mass shooter
who targeted black people killing ten
injuring three
and somehow
transitions into bragging that nobody
died in afghanistan while he was
president
it's a bizarre and disturbing political
moment take a look at this
we didn't lose one
american soldier think of it
not one
as opposed to last night which you saw
in milwaukee and you saw
i guess a total of 20 in different and
just as i'm coming off the stage i think
they had a tragic event in buffalo
just as i'm coming on the stage tragic
event in buffalo with
numerous people being killed in 18
months in afghanistan we lost nobody i
spoke with what what is the connection
between those two things
it's outrageous
that in the same sentence as domestic
gun violence
he's talking about afghanistan this
shooting in buffalo didn't happen thanks
to biden i mean is that what he's
suggesting that listen when i was
president nobody died in afghanistan but
there was a mass shooting in milwaukee
and a mass shooting
in buffalo
and i'm no longer president but biden is
like is that the implication
and in fact this is particularly
egregious it's particularly disgusting
because the right wing rhetoric cited in
the alleged manifesto of the buffalo
shooter
is exactly the type of stuff that
coalesced around trump and that was
fomented by right-wing media when donald
trump became president of the united
states it's
an outrageous comparison to make trump
also at one point
said something really weird
about elon musk saying musk has problems
and maybe trump's social media platform
is better and he again doesn't say it
correctly you guys know how trump
glitches all the time and he recently
got the name of his own platform
incorrect truth essential truth
essential yeah he again botched it it's
very weird see if you can understand
this oh it's hot and it's actually much
much better than twitter it's so it
blows twitter away everybody loves it
especially the engagement i mean it's
amazing elon musk so
i don't believe he's going to buy
twitter because you have so many fake
accounts the bots
all of the different things i think it's
going to be very interesting and he's
got some problems because he brought a
lot of stock that he shouldn't have
bought he got a lot of problems with
twitter but the twitter has a lot of
problems so go to truth truth social i
think you're going to find
truth essential
yeah so i guess he's making the point
that truth sensual is better than
twitter and maybe even better than truth
social and then lastly trump says he's
writing a book called the crime of the
century about how i guess the election
was stolen from him kind of getting sad
at this point anything about it they go
after other people
they don't want to go after criminals
that kill people on the streets they go
after others they go aft they like going
after republicans that's what they
really like this is the greatest this is
the crime of the century i'm actually
writing a book about called the crime of
the century i don't think you'll enjoy
it you'll be very depressed when you're
well i i just don't believe trump's
writing anything trump doesn't read and
trump doesn't write so none of it is
making sense to me so a completely
depraved event trump doesn't know up
from down day from night left is right
unclear what's going on but he continues
to be completely unempathetic in every
way to everything going on in the world
and next let's go to our interviews with
some of his supporters okay i've
this really should be you know we have
all these clips on youtube 10 million
views 8 million views 6 million views
this should really be one of our most
viewed clips ever on youtube i'm not
saying it will be but it should be
we were on the ground in texas austin
texas this weekend for the trump event
our correspondent luke beasley was there
luke this is the second time luke has
done stuff on the ground for us he's
doing an incredible job you can find his
youtube channel at davidpakman.com luke
that's l-u-k-e okay
um we're going to go through some of
these clips of luke talking to people
and i mean to just prepare yourselves i
don't think we've ever seen anything
like this this combination of ignorance
delusion paranoia conspiracy thinking
let's just jump right in playing for the
audience what that sign is all about
well
that's saying is about uh open border
yeah you know
every country protects the
the
the country the people
by the border every country have a
border why
buy them
so the sign says biden just dropped the
bomb on us the american people what can
we do now wait until 2024. what about if
we lose again so can we do something yes
we can the real question is can you pay
the price there's some tips then you
should be do i no ever give a job to
this illegal people and not ever buy
something from them okay anyway by the
way it's the it's so funny because
corporations keep hiring undocumented
immigrants the message really shouldn't
be to joe biden it should be to the
corporations and we've had a justice
system in the in the u.s for a long time
republican or democrat alike
that they don't really go after the
companies hiring the undocumented
immigrants anyway continue you're bored
but you're you understand that at the
border
thousands upon thousands of people are
getting detained every single day and
thousands of people are being deported
so we're enforcing the border just maybe
not as much as you would like
well
i don't think i don't think a thousand
people is the departure i think nobody
is deported right now so this is an
individual
who has been convinced
that all deportations have stopped under
joe biden obviously that's not true but
he believes it
yes thousands of people are being
deported
before but no no no under under joe
biden
no so look how do you argue with that
nah there's nobody being deported now
well if you believed that i could
understand being confused but of course
deportations have obviously continued
under joe biden next clip this is about
the election being stolen
and people's
feelings about it runs in 2024
and he loses do you think it'll also be
stolen again
it could be possibly but there's no way
to
say that it will be or won't be
and how will you tell if it is or is it
like do you think he could just lose
fair and square beautiful yeah he could
very possibly but i mean
we feel this last election was rigged
and
that there are a lot of unknown voters
that have passed and how do you vote if
you're dead
so the dead voters conspiracy widely
debunked
you're saying people used the names of
dead voters yes to vote even though that
hasn't been
shown on any of the court cases or
anything
but research from who i'm not exactly
sure research he's not sure about shows
dead people voted and i'd have to ask
the person who told me this and he's not
with see that's a fast that's actually a
very interesting thing
i'd have to ask the person who told me
this about the research well you should
have asked that right away in other
words this guy accepted it now that luke
is saying well what's your what's your
evidence for dead people voting he goes
i'd have to ask the person who told me
well that's what you should do right
away that's hopefully an instructive
moment here's another woman who feels
that the election was stolen
from donald trump
um and then 2020 you think it was stolen
yeah from trump for sure and what makes
you believe that
i just i believe it i when i just vote
here in austin the register in austin
texas man when
i was uh changing states and she was
laughing at me like a week and a half
before the election going haha this
election has already been decided i was
in the car i had a witness i'm a
caregiver i was driving
do you think she had a witness
she just meant since biden was so ahead
in the polls no he was not ahead without
polls and no doubt no i mean like uh
polling was cynical and uh
no no no no no no because i bet money
was somebody that biden will win but it
wasn't because i had inside information
i mean just beautifully done there by
luke
i don't have insider information it's
just a feeling just a feeling and just
with the comment i mean just walk around
walk around the comments she heard while
walking around austin and her feeling
proves to her that there was a national
conspiracy to steal the election from uh
trump and by the way she she voted in
texas where trump won so why would they
be talking in texas where trump won i
mean just none of it makes sense
walk around yeah all right so as you can
tell this is extraordinarily disturbing
this may be the most interesting clip of
all luke speaks to a couple
now the guy is wearing an american flag
vest
a backwards american flag t-shirt and
then the woman with the guy is wearing a
save what does it say i guess it's a
save america dress you'll notice that
when they realize that the interview's
not going super well she whispers to the
guy that maybe they should end this and
she walks away this is really good work
on the ground check this out i'm here
with the best looking people at this
event what are you guys hoping to see
here at the uh
the speech we're looking for anything
that has to do with election fraud uh we
came to hear dinesh and the new movie
2000 mules how to avoid this going
forward imagine being like i want to
figure out how to avoid fraud going
forward i'm going to go to an event and
listen to dinesh d'souza
my recommendation so your whole audience
is everybody needs to take off sometime
in november let's get to every ballot
location with video and start
videotaping this so it doesn't happen
again
okay what about you and i'm from
philadelphia pennsylvania where
obviously they had 1100 mules um there
there were no mules and i mean listen i
learned
there were zebras spotted at some
polling places
and an occasional donkey but there have
been no mules whatsoever
i just wanted to ask dinesh what is it
that we could do differently for the
next election can you imagine and
obviously you know it's really nice to
be around a lot of other patriots
so here's my question on that when i
hear people talk about this i want to
give it the time of day but then you
look at every official medium that you
would make you know prove that the
courts all those things
and it's not like there's no even people
that trump appointed
so this is great the woman says the
courts are corrupt and luke points out a
lot of those courts are run by trump
appointed judges the woman has no answer
she just turns and looks at the guy she
literally she just gave she just white
flagged and just looks at the guy it's a
good question so the thing is we all
know that it happens
so we i don't know that but is that i
don't know that well i need evidence to
believe something like that yeah i don't
know i know so listen it's this how
about this social media only seems to
censor liberals because they never talk
how great biden is they only seem to
censor liberals i assume he means
conservatives like this guy it's just
nothing's making sense
81 million people have you have to see
anything pro biden how about you
i think biden's done good stuff there's
some providing stuff
american rescue plan getting out of
afghanistan managing the russia ukraine
war taxes at its 40-year high understand
taxes at a 40-year high biden hasn't
done tax reform that's super interesting
taxes are biden hasn't done stuff on
taxes
given giving baby formal to immigrants
coming over the border except the um but
on the baby formula i think you do
understand that that's like
point zero zero percent one percent of
baby formula
are you affected by the baby formula i'm
not but if they don't get it their
babies starve if americans here they can
find other ways to get it but they're
stuck detained what about the americans
that are affected
and we need to help them as well and
that's what we're trying i'm sure
they're trying to do any immigrant of
course not okay they're all important
like the fact that our tax money goes to
the ukraine where it gets london back to
these corrupt politicians the tax money
goes to the ukraine where it gets
laundered back
what and the
media journals that are all liberal much
like yourself you keep on spinning this
there's no escaping he has done nothing
right man this is this is real much like
yourself
kid
um he took to talk to a guy about the
death penalty
the guy said the women should be killed
um women should be killed uh if they
have an abortion do you like i mean
listen he's for the death penalty
he believes abortions murder
you do the math um so big news roe v
wade
looks like it's gonna be overturned yeah
what was your reaction to that
so no that's great it was horrible you
know horrible uh ruling in the first
place uh and all they've done is
muddy it up since then
so i think uh it's about time
okay and then in your ideal country what
would the rules slash laws be
on people getting abortions
everybody has the right to life
life starts at conception
it's
science
you know this is a human life
okay
we should protect life always
and the punishment have you gotten
abortion
what do you think when you take a life
an innocent life
should be murder
it oh it should be murdered you didn't
say you should be murdered
like should the person get death penalty
yes
he thinks people should get the death
penalty for having an abortion you know
what happens when
say for instance a guy kicks a woman in
the in the stomach
that's he gets a murder sentence in many
states
for the death of that child
kill the women who have abortions quite
a scene uh and then lastly
here is um there there's a this is an
interesting thing there's lots of folks
who are just obsessed with communism and
socialism but when you ask them any
follow-up questions they don't know what
the hell is going on here's a woman
who's very very angry about communism at
the trump event what are you hoping to
see
besides trump just like what do you want
to hear
oh
because i came from a communist country
and trump is the one who fights for
america
and
who's communist in our country who's
pushing communism okay i came from a
vietnam you know vietnam is a communist
country now and that's why we love
vietnam
we love vietnam by boat and we
we don't like um you know communists i
understand not liking communism what's
the connection to liking trump
because
he's a doer he
he loves um everyone and he wants to
save america from you know the liberal
it's going to the left and it's not good
so it's it's
it's very bad so that's why
i'm here today crystal clear explanation
to support him because he's
you know he's fighting for it
so what's something that the left is
doing that's super far left
because
uh they
they support china and we don't like
china you know
china is a communist country communist
people
and by the way increasingly china is not
really a communist country i mean
they're they're run by the party but
it's increasingly a capitals it's
china's complicated but it certainly has
no connection to reality in terms of
what this woman is saying
they spread the
you know
um
they they want to compare they want to
um
they want to
you know to make everybody
you know under them they want to make
everybody under them and the us supports
them so
they
because
you never been to a communist country
i've been to china you've been to china
and what do you see in china what did
you see what do you see can you tell me
i'm curious i saw a lot of things but
i'm curious how this relates to the
democratic party
oh man
oh
because democrat because i think both
the republican and democratic party are
pretty much not communist
no i don't think so no she doesn't agree
with that
wow uh so that's what's going on in
america that's what's going and so when
we continue talking about how do we
deprogram how do we get through
that's the full scope of what we're up
against excellent work by luke beasley
you can find his youtube channel
at davidpakman.com
luke and let us know if you want to see
luke at more of these events
wow i'm going to need to take a break
just to recover from so many high-level
ideas we'll be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
okay the reawaken america tour continues
all across the country this is this sort
of right-wing conspiracy christian type
event it's a weird mix of different
constituencies but very often people
like
former trump national security adviser
michael flynn will speak at the event
sometimes eric trump will speak at the
event and we're going to look at a
couple of clips just to show you uh kind
of the disconnect from reality but also
the kind of level of danger that is
implicit in some of these things we're
going to start first with eric trump
eric trump is not known to be the
smartest of the trump kids but here he
seems determined to prove
he's the least smart saying the real
pandemic in the united states isn't
covered the real pandemic is fentanyl
take a listen to this so she's supposed
to be in charge of the southern border
you have more fentanyl coming across by
the way the real pandemic in this
country
is fentanyl let's be very clear about
that the real pandemic in this country
is fentanyl it's not coveted it's
fentanyl now
fentanyl is a problem and we'll talk
about uh it's a synthetic opioid we'll
talk about fentanyl in a moment
but this is absurd for a couple of
reasons first you hear people cheering
why would people cheer well do they
really care about fentanyl no
they care about fentanyl in that it's an
opportunity to say the real issue isn't
covered any opportunity to say that they
love and number two because they
associate fentanyl with the southern
border it's another opportunity to
attack joe biden for what they wrongly
believe has drastically changed on the
southern border since donald trump left
and joe biden came in but let's talk
about using the term pandemic for
fentanyl drug overdoses aren't
contagious in the literal sense now sure
there are trends of drug usage there is
group think there is peer pressure i get
that drugs go in and out of style
but covid is literally contagious
fentanyl is not so to say the real
pandemic isn't the contagious
communicable disease it's drug overdoses
is absurd if a person on fentanyl
sneezes near you
they might give you covet if they also
have it they're not going to give you
fentanyl overdose
now in terms of numbers if we look at
deaths by cause in the united states in
2021
you see that last year 415 000 americans
died of kovid and 71 000 americans died
of fentanyl so it's about one-fifth the
number now it's a major issue for sure
i'm not diminishing the crisis around
fentanyl uh we we have to understand
that not only is it a small fraction of
the death relative to covid uh that we
also need to consider the legal status
of drugs in making that number as high
as it is well what do i mean
part of the issue many fentanyl
overdoses and and uh overdose deaths are
people who aren't even trying to consume
fentanyl they're accidentally taking it
because of how people obtain drugs in
the united states because of the
criminalization of drugs right the war
on drugs has a big role to play
sometimes fentanyl is added to cocaine
sometimes fentanyl is uh used in pressed
pills meant to look like
oxy or other opiates sometimes it's put
in all sorts of different drugs that
people are getting so you could
dramatically reduce fentanyl deaths by
treating drug addiction as a public
health matter rather than a criminal
matter which the american right is very
uh uh unwilling to do so on four or five
different levels just off the wall
bonkers here is eric trump here's one
just like a bonus clip
this is kind of funny and sad
i guess a trump one flag started to be
unveiled in the background and eric
trump says it's the greatest flag better
even than the american flag i guess
i love the carolinas you guys are the
greatest and honestly when i came here
and i saw
raise that flag again over there that's
the greatest flag
wow
[Applause]
trump won it says
is there a single person in this room
that thought that joe biden won the last
election
and neither do i guys
neither do i and our country is an
absolute mess right now i mean it is
guys we dedicated our life to this
mission believe me we're the last family
in the world that needed to get into
politics right we have so much money the
last place i ever really needed to be
was here with people like you in fact
most of my life i've been spent i've
spent trying to stay away from people
like you but we did it by choice we did
it by choice delusional and the crowd
cheers let's look at one more clip from
this event so we looked at the eric
trump clips from the reawaken america
tour let's now look at one michael flynn
clip michael flynn is the former
national security adviser to the failed
former president donald trump flynn uh
was uh convicted and ultimately pardoned
by donald trump he showed up and he said
trump is currently the president trump
not trump should be president
not trump won but they didn't give it to
him he is saying trump currently is the
president of the united states and
people believe it
and people cheer and i still say it they
and wherever the damned live stream is
you know donald trump is still the
president of the united states
they can call me whatever they want
there it is right there
now they can call me whatever they want
because there's no way in the world that
81 million i don't see 81 million people
wearing buildback better hats
that's because there's no cult around
biden people just want a calm normal
president and they want to live their
lives
okay so there's michael flynn um you
know one of the things i genuinely
wonder
if trump is currently the president
why aren't they blaming trump for the
high gas prices
if they believe the president is
responsible for inflation and they
believe trump is currently the president
this is sort of like basic logic
the president is responsible for
inflation
trump is the president
therefore trump is responsible for
inflation it's uh along the same lines
the question must be asked if trump's
currently president he obviously can't
run in 2024 because that would be his
third term and we don't allow third
terms here oh no no no but that's it's
selective blame assignment selective
belief in reality and um this i i don't
know how we fight that
in any kind of substantive way we just
have to outvote them there's no other
way there's no hey come over to our side
these beliefs are so extreme
and so far gone that i don't know how i
mean just think it's it's middle of may
the elections in early november
how how do we mass deprogram these
people and get them to see reason
between now and then i just don't know
of how we do it and so far nobody we've
interviewed has been able to tell me
let me know your thoughts if you think
there's any way we might be able to
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to david p
the eggman called in about the buffalo
terrorist shooting and right-wing media
the eggman says there's not been a lot
of coverage of it on right-wing media uh
maybe a lot of right-wingers won't even
know it happened take a listen to this
hey dave so that mass shooting that
occurred in buffalo new york is kind of
close to my house you know not very
close but in the area so i watched on
the news regularly since it happened and
i'm and i'm sorry but i pay for fox news
and all the right-wing news channels
also because i have no internet by the
way there's really if you have cable
there's really no way not to pay for fox
fox isn't a channel where you can say i
don't want it so unfortunately any of us
who have a cable subscription
you have no choice but to pay for fox
news and that's that's a real shame
sorry i have to get cable so i flip back
on all the news channels and the only
ones carrying it well the only ones are
the so-called left-wing liberal channels
right cnn msnbc and i do have like
newsmax max and
news now there's other right-wing news
channels dave you ever hear about news
now it's really and oh and anyway
none of those channels were carrying the
shooting and i went i would go out and
come back in my house all weekend long i
just kept checking
none of the right-wing channels were
covering the mass shooting the racist
mass shooting in buffalo new york this
morning i turned the news to go to work
and i did see it on fox and friends a
little bit
do you think that the
left-wing media is showing it too much
or the right-wing media is
avoiding it because a white guy killed
black people it's obviously racist
what's going on dave shalom all right
yeah shalom to the eggman no this so so
a couple different things one
in the first 48 hours after such an
incident um it is major news and it
makes sense that it would be covered i
don't think the media outlets covering
it are covering it too much there is one
other thing going on on the right a lot
of stations are very minimally covering
it or not covering it at all because of
the obviously right-leaning
great replacement theory racist white
nationalist neo-nazi motivations of the
shooter
but we've also seen as we looked at
earlier in the show
fox news doing the well you know violent
video games might be what's to blame
here
and fox news talking about oh terrorists
might come through the southern border
from other countries but what about the
domestic terrorists that's here and that
killed 10 people so the what the
right-wing media outlets that are
covering it are covering it in a
completely dishonest way i don't know
what's worse not covering it at all
or covering it in a way that completely
distorts people's understanding of it
but the eggman's conclusion is accurate
people who only get their news from
right wing media
if they know about the mass shooting in
buffalo are going to have a very skewed
perspective on what it is that took
place and we'll talk about this more on
today's bonus show this is terrible news
pennsylvania u.s senate candidate john
fetterman has suffered a stroke but says
that he's well on his way to a full
recovery this is the primaries tomorrow
okay so we're going to talk about that
mitch mcconnell says that the senate is
going to pass the largest ukraine aid
package ever on wednesday
and lastly elon musk says that the
twitter legal team came to him and said
sir you violated an nda a non-disclosure
agreement what's that all about and
what's happening with musk purchasing
twitter i still i didn't think it was
going to happen and i still don't think
it will
um all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show get access to the
bonus show today by signing up at
joinedpakman.com or get access to the
bonus show at a discount on monday may
30th that's memorial day memorial day
there will be no new show we'll be off
for the holiday but we will be doing a
one-day membership special if you've
been thinking ah maybe i'll get a
membership i don't know
the perfect day the best day to sign up
is monday memorial day just get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com
and in the morning on memorial day
you'll get an email telling you how to
sign up